allowing for people to get spectacularly
wealthy when they get lucky based on
their own intelligence right they they
they produce something that's immensely
valuable to us a new antibiotic and we
should let them get rich right and if if
you have an alternative to that well by
by all means uh express it but no one is
conducting that research at fisa
precisely because it isn't profitable so
this tells us precisely the mentality
that governs at fisa and when indeed
there is in
you might find that it came from bio
entech in Germany who were funded by the
German taxpayers and you might find that
fisa's profits were garnered by charging
the American taxpayers who paid for that
fisa uh innov apparent fisa Innovation
but actually a bio inch Innovation the
problem is as Russell is alluding to the
entire system is rigged you don't want
to create a system where big Pharma is
completely uh unable to be sued if they
kill a whole bunch of people